I know they're by Max Keiser this is the
Kaiser report lots of stuff happening
I'm gonna find out myself what's
happening momentarily
let's ask Stacy well max you know how
we're always nearly at war and it's
nonstop nearly at war well there was an
interesting piece written by Tucker
Carlson this week and the hyper-partisan
America of course when you know red team
is not allowed to talk to blue team and
blue team's not allowed to talk to red
team because they're each side is
totally fascist and like horrible
authoritarian and stuff like that but
you know we're outside of that bubble of
their insanity so we're gonna look at
this headline about you know Tucker
Carlson of Fox News was looking at this
like you know this ramped up to war
against Venezuela
apparently like we're ready to invade
right so he was asking an American
conservative why are these professional
war peddlers still around pundits like
max boots and Bill Kristol got
everything after 9/11 wrong but are
still considered experts one thing that
every late-stage ruling class has in
common is a high tolerance for
mediocrity standards declined the edges
fray but nobody in charge seems to
notice they're happy in their sin occurs
and getting richer in a culture like
this there's no penalty for being wrong
the talentless prosper rising inexorably
towards positions of greater power and
breaking things along the way it
happened to the Ottomans max boots is
living proof that it is happening to
America
the rise of mediocrity and the rise of
experts that aren't experts but failures
mmm you know I think of the Philadelphia
Flyers of the 1970s they had a guy in
their team named Schultz it was the
enforcer and when Bobby Clark was
threatened they'd send this guy out to
intimidate and beat up anyone on the
opposing team who tried to interfere
with Bobby Clark so the Liberals in
America they consider themselves to be
living in pedestals high above the
masses and they're never wrong and they
have the more
i ground and occasionally when their
policies are exposed as fraudulent and
without merit and to kowtow to the worst
elements of core policy and empire and
their don't want to deal with their
unmasking they bring in a max boat or
william kristol to beat people up their
thugs max boot and bill kristol are our
thugs they're the enforcers for the left
so they go in and they kick people in
the game of bloody nose so again i want
to point out his sentence here that he
says one thing that every late-stage
ruling class has in common is a high
tolerance for mediocrity when I see a OC
who is the opposite of mediocre it
really puts into dramatic visual
representation how mediocre Hillary
Clinton was that they had massive
billions of dollars in order to try to
get people to you know the voters who
still have some say you know like this
woman like this woman a Jeb Bush when he
was like clap for me clap for me they're
total mediocrities that are being
foisted upon us and told that we have to
support war we have a mediocre financial
system we have a mediocre elite class
it's not just max boot it's not just
bill kristol it's Hillary Clinton it's
Al Gore it's you know George Bush it's
Jeb Bush it's Ted Cruz it's you know
almost the entirety of our class of
Theresa May is everybody is a mediocrity
they can't they're so blah and we're
told that we must go into war to fight
these but you know I wanted the reason
why I brought this headline up was that
safety in a moose the author of the
Bitcoin standard responded to this with
such the opposite of mediocrity like
with just powerful insights into why we
have non-stop war and why these
mediocrities rule so first of all he
said fiat money allows wars with no real
cost to governments which makes
detestable bloodthirsty Chicken Hawk
scum like max boot and Bill Kristol who
have never faced costs for their
warmongering the perfect so-called
foreign policy experts
safety no mooses point about hard money
is well-taken this is why he's reviled
by that fake economist Francis Copeland
in the UK Francis Coppola yes Francis
Coppola is the dilettante who likes to
criticize safety no moose for no
particular reason other than her own
failings as a socialite
but his point about hard money is that
it discourages mediocrity discourages
starting wars paid for by printing cash
and you know you see this at the end of
empire mediocrity rules and this bread
and circuses is turning into for America
anyway free fiat money or modern
monetary theory it's another bread and
circuses program giving away free money
to the masses give away free money and
to keep them quiet and it encourages
mediocrity and ALC the brilliant
politician from New York Cortez is like
brilliant entrepreneur brilliant
politician and she's very young in her
career and she's a threat to all that
are mediocre you know if she were a
technologist she'd be Bill Gates or Elon
Musk but she's a politician so back to
safety Ned there are five more tweets
I'm going to go over here and looking at
hard money and how hard money allows for
basically the destruction of mediocrity
because they must fail they do fail
because if they can't garner the wealth
if they can't attract capital their
ideas feel fail if they if their
mediocre ideas lead us into wars that
cost us the national wealth that for
example like when France sent all their
gold over here to fight the American
Revolution what happened to them once
they spent all their gold well they were
decapitated because they had no longer
any money to feed their population well
here is in 2003 Wolf of its told
Congress the Iraq war would be
practically costless it turned out to
cost more than two trillion dollars with
hard money Wolfowitz would have had to
raise the two trillion dollars before
war with easy money he can get his car
on and leave taxpayers footing the bill
for decades under hard money governments
had to finance our operations from their
citizens which made Wars possible when
necessary but bankrupted governments
that engage in unnecessary war war was
limited a contained too expensive armies
Kings were careful to not decimate
needlessly alright well it encourages
competition when you have hard money and
the people that are against our money
are people who don't want to compete
they just want to be Ron ca'se they want
to be rent seekers they want to skim off
the top they're want to be fiat money
printers and that's what we have we have
you know Ben Bernanke was at the Fed now
he works for Citadel there guy who runs
Citadel just made a hundred million
dollars last year by getting guys like
Ben Bernanke who's supposed to be
running the Fed to engage in unlawful
activities insider trading collusion
sedition you name it Ben Bernanke's
guilty of it and that's the definition
of a traitor but he's lauded as some
kind of intellectual and unfortunately
he's killing his country so you know
again under fiat system you could be as
stupid as we want especially whoever
controls the printing press of the Fiat
system and the global fiat currency is
the US dollar so the US dollar gets to
act the those who print the US dollar
get to act dumber and dumber than any
other people on earth now in the United
Kingdom they feel like you know they
that they're the little poodles of
America so that they get to act even as
dumb as Americans can so that's why you
have the likes of Gavin Williamson you
know their defense undersecretary sort
of person who's like we're gonna use
hard power against China you know if
they had to come up with gold to back up
trying to attack China with their 1.4
billion people and actually a lot of
gold and a lot of hard money and a lot
of citizens and a lot of military might
you know that would be a huge cost but
right now the citizens accept it because
it's tolerable because they could just
print more debt
I know I used to get into fights when I
was in grade school because I knew my
older brother would come in and you know
settle it yeah
and so Britain has been like this for
years they have a big mouth but they
they don't have the can't write the
checks all hat no cattle and when
they're separated from the eeo that's
gonna be exposed and I for one I'm gonna
be laughing myself silly right now but
right now the Bank of England the Bank
of Japan the ECB are under the auspices
of the US Federal Reserve Bank
essentially so here again safe teen
points out these non-stop Wars we have
been at war non-stop since 2001 non-stop
it's Oh everywhere also you're making
the connection to Venezuela
that's just another chapter it's not
going it's another chapter on this and
safety and a moose is who I'm reading
under hard money governments fought till
they ran out of their own money under
easy money governments can fight until
they completely consume the value of all
the money held by their people this is
why the century of central banking was
the century of total war yeah okay
that's exactly right and every single
country in the world every central bank
in the world is pursuing this money
printing and warring as you get fiat
referring to fiat except for one notable
exception Russia okay pay down all their
debt they've been buying gold and
China's doing trying to say the same
thing but you know Russia is serious and
so I mean it's okay for the UK to play
silly games and win silly prizes and
it's interesting that the America would
flush their sovereignty down the toilet
but there is at least one country out
there that's maybe looking about this
and thinking there's another way so he
goes then safety and almost goes into
the so-called electric electricity costs
of mining Bitcoin and this is very
interesting insight as well and a look
at the the cost of the of mining Bitcoin
as a as basically saving us from
Massacre bitcoins real cost is in
hardware and electricity needed to run
the network Fiats real costs is the
hundreds of millions of deaths financed
by government made omnipotent by
inflation which do you find more
expensive which would you rather
in the 21st century Bitcoin might end up
consuming half the world's electricity
but if it prevents one war that would be
the best bargain humanity ever got
bitcoin might be the most important
application of electricity can you think
of a better use for electricity than
neutering mass murderers well everyone
in Central and South America should be
part of safety no mooses patreon account
because he is articulating for them
the manifesto that they need to get rid
of the oppressor get rid of the Fiat
money get rid of the Empire that is
without question and get rid of Bill
Kristol get rid of max boots get rid of
Elliott Abrams the fact that Elliott
Abrams are still out running for US
foreign policy and military policy is
there should be like on a gold center or
on a Bitcoin standard the people of
America would be rising up is like not
this maniac my costing us real abrams
you know you show him a bitcoin wallet
he would shrink like the Wicked Witch of
the West and a bucket full of tears guys
bad news
he's another terrorist all right well we
got to take a break from all these
terrorists like Elliott Abrams and what
do we come back much more coming your
way don't go away
welcome back to the Kaiser report I'm
Max Keiser time now to go to New Jersey
when I say New Jersey you think Michael
Pento of Pento port calm Michael welcome
back thank you for having me on the
program again max it's a pleasure to be
with you I know it's a pleasure it's got
to be one of the greatest pleasures one
could ever experience if you're stuck in
New Jersey now Michael Pento I have a
question for you the Fed recently stated
that quantitative easing would no longer
be used for just so-called emergencies
but will it be primitive your thoughts
you know max I was in the come on your
program and make some jokes but it's
gotten to be such a serious issue in
this country and indeed throughout the
world that it's really not funny anymore
because the middle class is being
eviscerated and I find that the idea
that we place so much credibility with
the FOMC and members of other central
banks around the world I find it
absolutely ridiculous you know Janet
Yellen told us remember a few years ago
that quantitative tightening which is
the unwinding of QE would be like
watching paint dry she assured us that
because that's what she really believed
it was she trying to lie to us I'm not
quite sure but she also assured us there
would never be another financial crisis
in our lifetimes and then on October 3rd
also Jerome Powell the current head of
the Fed told the American public that
cutey would be on autopilot and that he
was going to raise rates to about three
to three and a half percent on the
overnight interbank lending rate and
then you know after about 10 years of
zero percent interest rates and a 300%
increase in stock prices a funny thing
happened for just a couple of months a
truncated period of time some prices
fell about 20 percent from their high
and about 7% in aggregate in 2018 and
that caused the Central Bank of the
United States to panic and then start to
begin the inexorable move towards more
QE after pretty
three point eight trillion dollars and
it's the same thing with the ECB the
European Central Bank and the Bank of
Japan I mean aren't people in this
country afraid embarrassed scared
petrified that interest rates in a
nominal sense will be at or near zero
forever and real interest rates are
going to be negative in other words with
me let me bow down to you
asset prices will perpetually increase
forever the middle class will be wiped
out and inflation will be much higher
than ever before for a much longer
period of time and nobody seems to care
but you all right okay well let's I'll
pick up on you or your idea there that
you know generally speaking we tend to
take a light-hearted look at some of
this stuff but let's let's let's take
the opposite point of view here let's
let's take the point of view that this
is actually since everyone's talking
about national emergencies these days
there is a true national emergency going
on with these zero percent interest
rates as you point out they jack asset
prices up which increase that wealth gap
and income gap and they caused all kinds
of evisceration of the middle class and
without the middle class you end up with
a lord and surf economy much like what
america tried to get away from with the
declaration of independence but Michael
Pento I want your comment on something
here because the IMF this past week the
two of the economists at the IMF the
International Monetary Fund suggested
that nations introduce a two-tier money
system to start introducing negative
interest rates on savers and cash so
this is not just 0% interest rate
Michael Pento this means a negative
interest rate that is just the bank
confiscating money directly out of your
account to encourage you to spend it
faster to not save to have no savings to
have no sovereignty to have no rights
Michael Pento your thoughts
well I mean it sounds like you're
agreeing with me
Maxwell because you know if central
banks are able to impose a negative
interest rate on your deposits that
means to me that you would be highly
encouraged to take your money out of the
banking system and then you would make
banks insolvent so that's not going to
be allowed to happen unless first they
have this crypto currency adopted either
on a federal level or an individual
banking level like we saw Jamie Dimon
all of a sudden embrace cryptocurrencies
because you cannot have the ability to
hoard cash and impose negative interest
rates so what I'm trying to say is that
individual freedom is being wiped out
along with the middle class so you don't
have the opportunity to hoard cash to
take cash out of the banking system you
are obligated now to lose get penalized
lose money and get penalized for saving
money in this country but nobody seems
to care max and here's the thing I want
to add that in this country we went from
in 2008 to today we increased the debt
the total non-financial debt by 18
trillion dollars max you know when you
have zero percentage rates and now we're
gonna go to negative interest rates
people are encouraged to do what borrow
more money and that's why you're seeing
you know auto loans being defaulted upon
by the millions like they were 7 million
was reported recently in the booming
amount of credit card debt and student
loan debt the national debt is 22
trillion dollars and the only thing
keeping this together is perpetual
interest rates at 0%
so here's the thing I want to mention to
you you know Wall Street is up some 18
percent in January alone just between
January and of the time of this
recording in in late to mid February and
I have to ask you a question of 18
percent because why because we're
guaranteed that central banks will keep
interest rates at a negative level in
real terms and
money forever so what here's the
question max when is it going to be a
good time if ever to normalize things
you know if you listen to the mainstream
financial media everything is perfect
you know the Dow Jones Industrials ESP
if I wondered it's trading at 17 times
forward earnings even though there's no
earnings road who cares because
everything's fine and dainty don't you
know the Federal Reserve has you back I
mean I don't people aren't people
concerned about the fact that they're
losing their freedoms and that you said
very succinctly the core of any free and
viable nation is a very strong middle
class not the top you know four hundred
families that owned almost all of the
wealth in this country not the fact that
the very poor are getting even more poor
as the days go by because I have to
spend most of their income on food on
fuel and on clothing and on shelter I
mean what this country's falling asleep
and I was gonna make jokes and I was
gonna you know have a light-hearted
conversation with you but this is
getting very very serious no I
understood and you know we it is a
serious topic and so you know let's
continue down this path you know the
idea that people are losing their rights
and losing their sovereignty and they're
losing their ability to save money and
it's becoming normalized or as Adam
Curtis made a film a documentary film in
the UK called hyper normalization about
how in the Soviet Union that lies simply
became normalized and the despicable
state of the Soviet economy just became
normalized and people just just went
with it now in this country this
arrangement of having the bank's just
basically leech onto your bank account
with a negative rate is becoming
normalized now I don't not to get too
political here Michael but you know the
fact is that a country that went through
that Russia and then now the Federation
Federation they are buying hundreds of
tons of gold they have no debt at all
and do you think you know again not to
get too political but I mean isn't that
the
a sign of a country that's seen the
writing on they've been through this
already they've seen how this movie ends
and doesn't end well and with price
fixing as tough as the Fed does the
price fixing is America's Politburo you
know that Jesse Powell is America's
communist dictator essentially by
dictating the price of money that's not
a capitalism that's frickin you know
communism and right there in the Federal
Reserve Bank in America meanwhile Russia
is saying you know what we know how this
ends
we're buying gold you know and we're not
and we're paying down all our debt your
thoughts Michael well you know you you
have a rise of socialism in this country
like I've never before seen in my life
you know you can you can have a State of
the Union address when a president gets
up and says you know we want to be a
capitalist nation and people sit there
from the most part and put frowns on
their plate on their faces you have
people like a OC come in to the fore you
have California now imposing an idea
called universal basic income give it a
try in fact it's being tried in many
places all around the world so I mean
we're heading towards it dystopian max
and as I said I don't see a lot of
people concerned about it because the
stock market right now is up 18% for the
for the year but here's a here's
something I want to comment and propose
to your audience you know in the Great
Recession we coming out of that Great
Recession central banks had a lot of dry
powder they had 500 25 basis points to
take debt service costs down down here
in the United States and indeed all over
the world that was the case but now
we're entering into a situation where
Japan they're year-over-year GDP growth
was 0.7 percent Italy is in an outright
recession Germany had a q4 18 print of
zero point zero percent here in the
United States we went from four point
two percent in q2 down to just one
percent in this this current quarter at
best earnings first earnings growth rate
is going from 20 percent throughout 2018
to a negative
number in q1 2019 so we have all these
incipient recessionary data points
coming out we saw retail sales and
durable goods and factory orders
industrial production or all
recessionary numbers but my question is
this okay well let's pop a cork in here
and take the stock up stock market up
18% because don't you know Donald Trump
loves chicken chow mein and that's his
favorite food down he's gonna shake
hands with GG paying and there's gonna
be a great wonderful trade deal but
here's the thing you know the Federal
Reserve doesn't have hundreds of basis
of points the lower interest rates the
ECB has no room to lower the discount
rate and the Bank of Japan has no room
to lower interest rates and the ECB just
got out of QE in December so I don't
know if there's this automatic you know
watershed move towards a booming economy
just because central banks are waxing
towards being more dovish yeah the stock
market is stock buybacks fueled by the
same free money so it's not a reflection
of earnings now give me I'll give you
two data points we have about 30 seconds
77 year old billionaire or Sam Zell
recently announced he's buying gold for
the very first time and in 2018 central
bank's bought more gold than any time
since 1971 so gold is in the ascent
Michael we've got about 20 seconds
managing money from since 2012 here at
Penn support I have never been more
bullish on the yellow metal a you and
even AG in a lesser extent because when
you know interest rates in nominal terms
are never gonna be more than zero and in
real terms are going to be negative and
headed more negative and the dollar is
probably topped out buy yourself some
gold Jerry
there you have it Michael Pento from
Pentos port dot-com one of the smartest
guys on Wall Street he actually has a
day job managing money you might check
out his website so you see what that's
all about thanks for being on the show
Michael thanks all right that's gonna do
it for this edition of the Kaiser report
with me Max Keiser and Stacey Herbert
like the
I guess Michael Pento Pento port comm if
you want to catch us on Twitter it's
cause a report until next time bye y'all
[Music]